who are the key people
to you in in this
evolution of the human being of the
leader is it Patricia is it showing you
the minister of defense is it like you
mentioned pescal the press secretary uh
what role do some of the others like
lavrov play
I think it's more rooted in the larger
context I mean individuals matter in
that context but it's just kind of like
the shared worldview and if you go back
to the early 1990s immediately after the
dissolution of the Soviet Union when
Yeltsin you know and uh the uh has come
to pass me Korean baller is pull it
apart there was an awful lot of people
who you know wanted to maintain the
Soviet Union not just Putin I mean you
remember after uh Gorbachev tried to
have the new Union treaty
um in um 1991 and there was the
emergency committee set up the coup
against Gorbachev it was because they
were worried he was going too far and
unraveling you know the union then as
well they were opposed to his reforms
there's always been a kind of a very
strong nationalist contingent that
became Russian nationalists over time
rather than Soviet you know hardliners
who you know basically want to maintain
the Empire the Union in some form and in
the very early part of the 1990s there
was a lot of pressure put on Ukraine and
all the other former Soviet republics
now independent states by people around
you know melushkov for example in Moscow
by you know other forces in the Russian
uh Duma not just you know vladimirovsky
and others but you know we're really
serious you know kind of what we would
call him like right wing you know
nationalist forces but it's you know
perversive in the system and it's
especially perversive in the kg being in
the security sector and that's where
Putin comes out of remember Putin also
was of the opinion that one of the
biggest mistakes the Bolsheviks made was
getting rid of the Orthodox Church as an
instrument of the state
and so there's this kind of
restorationist wing within the security
services and the state apparatus the
ones who kind of bring back Russian
Orthodoxy as a state instrument an
instrument of state power and they were
kind of you know looking all the time
about strengthening the state uh the
executive the the presidency and and so
it's everybody who takes part in that
and it's also there's a more power
honestly and they see Putin as their
vehicle for power I think people like
Sergey kirienko I knew kirienko back in
the 90s I mean my God that guy's all in
or like Dimitri medvedith
you know who was you know a warmer
fuzzier version of Putin certainly had a
totally different perspective wasn't in
the KGB did you say warmer fuzzy fuzzier
version yeah I mean he's kind of like he
was literally a warm personality I don't
know if he watched him during the
September 30th annexation the guy had
all kinds of facial twitches and looked
so rigid and stiff that he looks like he
might implode I mean that wasn't you
know how he was you know earlier in his
career and he you know had a different
view of Paris Striker we always have to
remember that Putin was not in Russia
during parastrike he was in Dresden
watching the um East German State Fall
Apart and you know dealing with the
starsy in a kind of place where you
weren't getting a lot of information
about what was happening in West Germany
or even what was happening back home in
perestroika and he has that kind of
group of people around him the Patra
chefs and botany cuffs and others and
Sergey van off and others you know from
you know the different configurations of
his administration who have come out of
that same kind of mindset and are kind
of you know wanting to put everything
back together again so there's a lot of
enablers there's a lot of you know power
Seekers and there are a lot of people
who you know think the same as him as
well he is a man of his times a man of
his context
you as a top advisor yourself and and a
scholar of Putin do you think it
actually now in his inner circle are
there people he trusts there are people
he trusts for some things
but I don't think there's people who
trust for everything I don't think he's
the kind of person who tells anyone
everything at all I don't think he's got
somebody I don't know he'll he's he's
com he I think he compartmentalizes
things he's often said that the only
person who trusts is himself
I think that's probably true he's the
kind of person who keeps his own counsel
I mean people talk about Kovalchuk for
example or you know kind of some of the
other people who are you know friends uh
with him that kind of go back to his
time in Saint Petersburg you know at
various points he seem to you know spend
a lot of time you know way back when
talking to people who are you know
people think of kind of more moderating
forces like Alexia kudrin but you know
it doesn't seem to be interacting you
know with them you know there are
obviously aspects of his personal life
you know does he
speak to his daughters does he you know
speak to you know kind of
lovers you know kind of in a way of
people speculate about you know kind of
who might be confide in but I would
greatly doubt that he would have deep
political discussions with them he's a
very guarded uh very careful person what
about sources of information then so
trust a deep understanding about
military strategies with
um for certain conflicts like the war in
Ukraine or even special
uh subsets of the war in Ukraine or any
kind of military operations getting
clear information deeply suspicious you
know of people and of information
and I think in a part of of the problems
that you know we see with Putin now
I mean I've come from isolation during
covet I'm I'm really convinced that you
know like many of us
yeah a lot of Putin's views have
hardened
and the way that he looks at the world
have been
shuddered in very dark Ways by the
experience of this pandemic
you know obviously he was in a bubble
different kind of bubble for most of us
I mean most of us are not bubbles with
multiple you know kind of palaces and
you know kind of the Kremlin
but you know we've seen you know so much
it's obviously a lot of this is stage
that isolation you know that kind of
making it very clear that he's the Tsar
the guy who is in charge making all the
decisions you know one individ table and
everybody else is at the other end but
you know it's very difficult then to
bring you know information to him in
that way he used to have a lot of
information bundled for him in the old
days by the presidential Administration
I mean I know that because it was a lot
more open in the past and I have a lot
of meetings with people in the
presidential Administration who brought
outside you know would say all Source
information you know for him and you
know kind of funneled in information
from different think tanks and
you know different viewpoints and
maybe a kind of more eclectic
Diversified set of information he would
meet with people you know you've heard
all the stories about where he had once
called up Masha gessen you know and had
to you know come in you know obviously a
you know a very different character as a
journalist and a Critic you know we've
heard about benedictive from Echo
Muscovy the you know the radio program
the the editor who uh Putin would you
know talk to and consult with he he'd
Reach Out people
um like Elizabeth for example the head
of Memorial he had some respect for her
and would you know sometimes just you
know talk to her you know for example
all of that seems to have come to a halt
and I think I think a lot of us worry I
mean us who you know watch Putin about
what kind of information is he getting
you know is it is it just the
information that he's seeking and
Gathering himself that fits into his
worldview and his framework we're all
guilty of that of looking for things it
gets to our social media preferences are
people just bring into him things that
they think he wants to hear like the
algorithm you know kind of like the
Kremlin working in that regard as he
himself you know tapping into sorts of
information that he absolutely wants and
remember he is not a military guy
he's a not preserved and he was sort of
trained in operations and you know
contingency planning
Sergey the defense minister as a civil
engineer was the former minister of
emergencies he wasn't a military planner
you know somebody like um the head of
the
Chiefs of Staff maybe a military guy you
know in this you know case from the Army
but he's also somebody who's in a
different part the chain of command he's
not somebody who would spontaneously
start you know telling Putin things and
Putin you know comes out of the FSB out
of the KGB of the Soviet era and he
knows the way that you know intelligence
get filtered and worked he's probably
somebody wants to consume raw
intelligence he doesn't probably want to
hear anybody else's analysis and he
survived in the past of you know picking
things up from people you know I've
taken part in all of these meetings with
him gone for hours because he's just
collecting he's collecting information
he's sussing people out he wants to know
the questions they ask he learned
something about the questions that
people ask the way that they ask them
you know so he's kind of soliciting
information himself and if he's cut off
from that information
you know because of circumstances
then you know how is he formulating
things in his head and again getting
into you can't get into his head but you
can understand the context in which he's
operating and that's where you worry
because he clearly made this decision to
invert Ukraine be out in the back of
most of his security establishment
you think so oh I think it's pretty
apparent well what uh
what would the security establishment
will be well that would be the larger
you know thinking the funneling in
information from the uh presidential
Administration from the National
Security Council it looks like you know
he made that decision
and then you know having worked in these
kinds of environments and it's not that
dissimilar you filter information up so
think about you know you and I are
talking for hours here
um if if you were my you know uh
basically uh you know senior official
and I'm your briefer I might only get 20
minutes with you
and you might be just like you know
looking at your watch the whole time and
thinking hang on a second I've got to go
and I've got this meeting and I've got
that meeting and yeah your point you're
not going to wait there so I give this
long explanation I've got to get to the
point and then I've got to then choose
for myself what's the information I'm
going to impart to you out of the 20
things I think are important
you know okay I've got 20 minutes maybe
I only get two minutes maybe you know
you get called out yeah and somebody you
know kind of interrupts something
happens I'm gonna get one minute two
minutes yeah I mean I wanted to remember
I had to give a presentation when I was
in government you know to um Henry
Kissinger you know for that defense
policy board and we plan bloody weeks on
this thing you know PowerPoints were
created teams of people were brought
together
and you know people were practicing this
we had all these you know different
people there and I said look Henry
Kissinger is an academic and a former
professor and you know I happened to you
know I'm going to watch him in action
he's gonna like
you know five seconds in if we'll if
we're lucky we get that far ask us a
question and just throw off our entire
presentation what is it that we want to
convey and that's exactly what happened
and then you know people aren't really
prepared or they wanted to convey and
they you know they'd be prepared a you
know a nice sort of fulsome you know
powerpoint-like approach we never even
got there and so God knows what you know
he took away from it at the end of it
and that's you know think about Putin
he's going to be kind of impatient he's
you know we see the televised things
where he you know it kind of sits at a
table a bit like you know people won't
necessarily see us here and he puts his
hands on the table he looks across at
the person who says so tell me you know
what's the main things I need to know
and of course the person's mind probably
goes blank you know with the kind of the
thought of like oh God what's the main
thing yeah and they go and they start
well Vladimir vladimirovich and you know
they they start the kind of you know
they're revving up being able to get to
the point and then he cuts them off so
you think about that and then you think
about well what information has he got
and then how does he process it and is
he suspicious of it does he not believe
it
and what inside of his own history then
you know leads him to make one judgment
over another